طار الرئيس بايدن على متن طائرة واحدة
لمدة 30 دقيقة تقريبًا مع هذا
الموظف من المستوى المتوسط يوم الجمعة قبل أن تكون نتيجة اختباره إي
ابية لكوفيد يوم الاثنين وف
ًا لرئيس البيت الأبيض ، م
ذ ذلك الحين ، تم اختبار بايدن سل
يًا عبر اختبار PCR وسيختبر مر
أخرى يوم الأربعاء ولكن  في غضون ذلك
، قال البيت الأبيض إن بايدن
سيستمر في جدوله كالمعتاد
إلى جانب ما اعترفوا بأنه
تعرض للتواصل الوثيق في بيان في وقت متأخر من يوم
الإثنين ، أشار السكرتير الصحفي جين
ساكي إلى إرشادات مركز السيطرة على الأمراض التي تقول إن الأشخاص الذين
تم تطعيمهم بالكامل ليسوا مضطرين إلى القيام بذلك.
الحجر الصحي بعد تعرض مثل هذا ، يتعين على
أي شخص حول الرئيس
أن يختبر سلبيًا لفيروس كوفيد يوميًا
ويقول البيت الأبيض إن هذا الموظف كان
سلبيًا يوم الجمعة لكنهم بدأوا
يشعرون بأعراض يوم الأحد ، سُئل أوساكي في
وقت سابق يوم الاثنين قبل إصدار
هذا الإعلان عن
تفشي محتمل  في البيت الأبيض ، هذا ما
قالته نتوقع أن تكون هناك
حالات اختراق في
جميع أنحاء البلاد  ر أه
وبالتأكيد أه في الحكومة الفيدرالية
أم وأهم شيء يجب ملاحظته
أه بالنسبة لك وللآخرين هو أن أه
ال 99 من أو أكثر في هذه
النقطة من البيت الأبيض موظفو
التطعيمات
موصى بها بشدة و
الموزع لدينا عملية شاملة للغاية
هنا
يلتزم بها الأشخاص الذين سيكونون على
اتصال وثيق بالرئيس وحتى
أبعد من
ذلك وتلك البروتوكولات تتجاوز
إرشادات cdc الآن كما قال ساكي إن
البيت الأبيض لا يخطط
لتغيير كوفيده  البروتوكولات في هذه المرحلة في
البيت الأبيض نيكي كارفاخال سي إن إن